it is one of the surest signs that
winters fading Major League Baseball's
pitchers and catchers report this week
to spring training the Miami Marlins
look very different this season
including at the top of the franchise
future Hall of Famer Derek Jeter became
a co-owner and CEO after last season
Jeff Glor met up with a one-time New
York Yankees captain in Miami to talk
about this next chapter in his life and
what's ahead on and off the field Thank
You Derek Jeter has taken the field
thousands of times but doing so as an
owner is a different ballgame you got to
win everybody over here yeah we got to
earn people's trust a generation ago
Jeter stepped into the most storied
franchise in sports and won five World
Series championships in 20 years
[Applause]
[Music]
in Miami he's essentially starting over
he traded away the team's best players
including last season's national league
MVP Giancarlo Stanton he's also removed
a number of longtime employees know he's
running around out there it has not been
an entirely smooth transition how much
is the criticism this positive by nature
and I try to look at the fact that we do
have an end game everyone gets
criticized I think it's easy to
criticize we haven't played a game yet
right the bottom line is we're trying to
fix something that's been broken Jeter
did retain the team's manager there's
nothing that says you can't win right
now another Yankee legend Don Mattingly
the two played together briefly in the
90s I think we're probably fairly
aligned as far as you know the way we be
thinking about going about it people
were like that's all Yankee stuff looks
like it's not such a bad example you
know it's not such a bad place to have
come from and to have learn from
ironically the last time the Marlins
made the playoffs was in 2003 when they
went all the way against the Yankees
have to bring it I don't know why we're
talking about this
you still Yankee fan I am yeah just not
if we're playing them right I mean this
is an organization where I owe
everything to and you know I have a
great relationship with the Steinbrenner
family I will continue to do so but it's
it's yeah it's it'll be strange when we
play the Yankees because there hasn't
been a day in my life that I've rooted
against them Jeter has little idle time
these days he and his wife Hannah just
welcomed daughter Bella six months ago
it's by far the most gratifying thing
I've ever been a part of nice to go home
at night it is because regardless of how
your day went at work when you get home
and you see a smile on your daughter's
face it it makes it all worthwhile
she have a baseball she doesn't she
doesn't she throws things though she
does she does she throws things how old
you gonna be man ten
it is his daughter's generation that he
seems focused on building baseball for
the future and being exceedingly careful
about discussing baseball's problems of
the past Roger Clemens Barry Bonds those
whose names have been associated with
peds should they be in the Hall of Fame
it's a tough question right it's it's
you know a question for if someone is
accused or someone has proven to do you
know some opinions change over time some
people are bullish on their opinions
your date's autonomous well yeah I am
you know why because you know I've
played with players you know you play
with guys that you've built
relationships with over time and and you
get close to them and you develop a bond
and people make mistakes not saying you
can condone those mistakes people do
make mistakes but yeah you're right I
mean it is a tough question and
you know I don't make those decisions
when you look back 20 years from now you
see these kids who are here now who are
5 years old what do you want them to say
about you Derek Jeter the owner that we
made this a fun place to come that we
built something that they can be proud
of I didn't get into this to having an
exit strategy I'm come here to do it
in Miami yes
in Miami he was always such a class act
and continues to be so clearly and he
was always the player that universally
almost all fans lights you know even
even Red Sox fans they don't love all
Yankee fans but they respected Derek
Jeter but this this has been different
because he's never faced this sort of
criticism before and the moves that he's
made both removing players and some
longtime employees but he makes no
apologies for it and he says I have a
plan it's a long-term plan and we have
to be sustainable long-term and I have
to make changes quickly and decisively
and while he didn't answer the question
about his teammates former teammates I
thought he handled that very very well
he's clearly a diplomat that was a
classy way to do it yeah and I think
from his perspective there's there's
there's guys who did this consistently
over long periods of time who knew the
mistakes they were making for a long
period of time there were guys who may
have made a mistake once or twice
and so I think he's trying to draw the
line but I'll bet he loves best dad dad
dad Bella's dad that's the best one
thank you Jeff